the right-hander matt shoemaker he's
been
pretty good looking to start a little
bit of a consistent hot streak here i
i've enjoyed watching him pitch he knows
how to pitch see what he can do against
the pirates here today adam frazier
looks for his first hit of the series
and there's a line drive base hit adam
frazier singles to right to start this
ball game brownie it never ceases to
amaze me how quick he gets to the
baseball i mean the barrel control he
has in his ability just to just drop the
hands on top of that pitch that's
upstairs
another guy looking for his first hit of
the series in fact hitless in his last
11 at bats is philip evans
and towards center field and here we go
first and second so the first two guys
who were hitless in the series deliver
to start this ball game evans to center
field
moves frazier to second base brown we
call that a diamond cut because it
splits the diamond in half look at that
right there
equal sides on both shoemaker in early
trouble and here's brian reynolds
and the other way toward left dropping
and that's fair and the pirates take the
early lead
as reynolds pulls into second with a
double it's one nothing brownie you've
got to see mitch garver's reaction on
this swing his head goes down almost
immediately as soon as reynolds makes
contact because he sees it's right in
that bermuda triangle right outside of
the third baseman's opportunity to catch
it outside of the left fielder and he
dropped his head down was so
disappointed that's that area that's
just unguardable as you see evan's at
third reynolds at second no one out
three and two the count on colin moran
and this is lifted to center and the
runner at third evans will tag buxton
will concede that run and hold the
runner at second so sacrifice fly for
moran two-nothing pirates yeah and that
had to feel good for the red beard to
you know put a ball in play with a
little bit of a charge into it deep
enough to score that run from third not
gonzales
half swing i think he went yep two away
a couple of veterans battling each other
here with shoemaker hoping this will be
the last pitch of the inning
bouncer to short polanco sense
and over to hasta dio to end the inning
the pirates scored two runs on three
hits they strand one we've played one
half at target field will crow added to
the roster today he'll make his first
start as a pirate right shaking out his
left hand after that last swing white
uniform white batting gloves
there it is that's a fair ball toward
the corner playing him that way is
phillip evans and arise who sent a
couple of fouls down the left field line
put one in fair territory for a leadoff
single good to see that that's classic
luisa rise right there and i think his
eyes got a little big after you hit that
home run frankly
what was for him a long home run to
right field earlier this season here's
donaldson so far the rise has started
the twins half with a single
slice to right a base head and a rise
around second will go to third well the
twins doing what the pirates did with a
couple of early hits in their half of
the first inning i got to tell you
that's a professional job of hitting
right there and i hope all his teammates
see watch where this ball is it's down
and in he's going to wait a long time
he knows that will crow throws a lot of
sliders we know that statistically so
far he's got two strikes he's just gonna
wait and identify the pitch if he gets
beat on the fast while he does but he's
able to muscle that ball to right field
that's a great two strike at bet here's
cruz one for seven in the series
oh there we go strikes them out one down
crow i think he said i'll take your
ground ball and i'll raise you to that
right right yep change up that you know
it looked like cruz saw it but he saw it
too late good pitch so now buxton
average power on base percentage all
high
driven to left buxton comes through and
that's what happens arise scoring and
donaldson the second base a bullet to
left and it's two to one can't over
emphasize what it means to hit two and
all instead of owen two and byron just
for so many years got himself in tough
counts early but you will not get him
out low in the strike zone when he's
ahead in the count you just he just
won't do it kirloff pittsburgh native
oh stabbed look what i found will crow
will take it that way a line drive
double play out that helps out will crow
in his first inning and his first start
as a pirate through one inning facing
the guy where you kind of want to live
in that area
couldn't get there
popped up and in play yes
colin moran for a second out yeah that's
a big out right there some really good
sliders turtle pops out yeah there you
go again against the crow whoa i see
what you did there crow's first start
with the pirates again acquired over the
winner
and a great stop by gonzalez and a throw
to first to get donaldson one heck of a
play by egon wow what a great play i
mean we've we've talked about it time
and time again brownie his defense is
just you know it's a plus at so many
different positions this play right here
donaldson hits that slider out in front
i mean gonzo just wow full length what a
play i mean that ball almost turned him
completely backwards pointing towards
the outfield great play but gonzo gets
up in a hurry he knows his runner
understanding who is actually at the
plate so you don't rush through that and
make a bad throw
looking at a glock or the left-handed
batter here's the 2-2
swinging a crack bat lighter in the
center that'll drop in for a base hit
polanco aboard with a two out single to
center
good job right there good stay through
by ponco on that splitty down low strike
one buckle
yeah that's hit hard past the second
baseman arias out in shallow right
second straight hit for polanco yeah he
he snap hooked that ball right in the
hole right through the shift hits it
foul and then keeps it fair that second
time through i mean it shows how hard he
hits and we saw that last year a lot
stay shack sets stallings weights the
pitch swinging a fly ball out to left
carol off turning around and it's off
the wall played by buxton the center
fielder backing him up it's a double for
jacob stallings and the pirates have
second and third with nobody out i
thought for sure that one was going to
be a home run i was watching the
outfielders and they just kind of right
there at the end they shut it down and
thought that one was in the bullpen one
of the pirate pitchers ran over to maybe
try and catch the ball it hit like maybe
a third of the way up on the fence
polanco at third stallings at second
nobody out for newman here's the 2-2
pitch swinging a line drive up the
middle through base hit and polanco will
score stallings held at third rbi single
kevin newman and the pirates lead three
to one no there's still nobody out so we
can't be done right now get greedy and
with that infield in that enables newman
to garner a hit on that frazier against
the lefty has two hits today and
grounded and into right field frazier
brings home stallings and into third
goes newman the pirates have added on
they lead 4-1 three-hit dave for frasier
another great day for frey's i mean
really tough pitches early on gets down
on the count early and then once again
not trying to do too much that's simple
swing simple approach so one out and
here's polanco two for three today two
singles in a run
to right field and gregory polanco that
does clear the deck with a cannonball
you want a hot cup of coffee on a cold
day his third home run and the pirates
take a 6-1 lead and that smile never
ever gets old yes indeed 109.6 off the
bat perfect barrel with the 26 degrees
wins down five bottom eight nelson cruz
for three today one for ten in this
weekend series leads off
a high blast to left field and nelson
cruz tees off home run number seven
tying him for the league lead well he
hasn't been exactly sharp either but he
goes up there
with the right kind of approach every
time up and if you throw him a breaking
ball strike you're vulnerable
there's a little spinner that stays in
the middle of the zone and
he has just done that too many times to
that pitch back-to-back strikeouts and
now ostodil the last chance for the
twins are the pirates leading six to two
two innings for stratton he would love
to strike out the side in order would a
finishing touch that would be to this
stellar trip
little dribbler
this should do it and we can
well yes raise the jolly roger a little
scoop from colin moran they win six to
two they're gonna come home and the
buckos have a sensational road trip